VAN RIPER: I'm going to start.
I apologize for the delay.
I was about ready to throw that
guest's bad reader thing
through the window out there,
to get it to work.
Anyway, someone is going to
hear about that tomorrow.
I'm going to try to do some
real quick things.
Who's going to Silicon
Valley Code Camp?
No, keep your hands up.
I need to see who you are.
AUDIENCE: What was
the question?
VAN RIPER: Who is already signed
up to go to Silicon
Valley Code Camp in October?
All right.
You guys need to come and
see me to get one of
these really cool--
as Peter Kellner in the
front row tells me--
not a sticker.
It's a mule skin.
They're very special.
You didn't tell me
why it's special.
Oh, because it comes off, and
it doesn't trash your
important laptop.
So if you're coming to Code Camp
or if you're willing to
look me in the eye
and say, you're
going to sign up tonight.
Come by and get on
of these from me.
And if you want to learn more
about Code Camp, you should
talk to the guy who started it
all, several years ago, Peter
Kellner, in the front row.
Oh, how many Java User
Group members do
we have in the audience?
Awesome.
How many Google Developer Group
members do we have in
the audience?
It's OK if you raise your hand
twice, if you're in both.
That's what I thought.
We've got a lot of overlap.
OK.
Or maybe it's just the subset of
our 5,000-member GDG that's
also in the JUG is
here tonight.
Anyway, thank you
for all coming.
I'm actually wearing the old
GTUG logo because this is kind
of a special meaning, in that
we started the whole GDG
movement with a joint Java User
Group meeting that Kevin
and I ran over at the main
campus, to be the very first
meeting of what we called
Silicon Valley GTUG, Google
Technology User Group
back then.
That was over five years ago.
So this is kind of a blast from
the past, having a joint
meeting again.
Only this time, it's the younger
sibling that's now
grow up to be able to beat
up the older brother.
And we reached the 5,000
member mark.
[APPLAUSE]
So you JUG guys have
got to get working.
You're only at 3,300.
There's nothing wrong
with that.
I know we're really late.
So want to get this going.
I do want to give a shout out
to Paul in the front row,
who's been our Google Developer
Group photographer
for forever, since
the beginning.
[APPLAUSE]
Paul is leaving the area.
So he came out.
This is his last meeting.
So we really appreciate
his help.
And if someone has photography
skills or would like to be
doing things like blogging
about our events or on
Google+, talk to
us about that.
We'd love to have people helping
us share what we're
doing here.
I put on the Meetup, on Twitter,
and on Google+ the
YouTube link.
So make sure if you
have friends--
I'm sure you're going to think
this is a great talk by Hans.
And you're going to want
other people to see it.
So share that link with them.
And I'm going to stop talking.
Is there anything
I needed to say?
Turn your phones off.
And remember to turn them
on when you come back.
And we're very fortunate to
have Hans here all the way
from Germany.
So give him a big hand.
[APPLAUSE]
HANS DOCKTER: Good?
AUDIENCE: A little higher, on
your collar would be good.
HANS DOCKTER: Yeah, welcome to
this talk, which tries to
bridge the people who have an
interest in Android, to people
who have an interest
in Gradle.
So my first question would be
who of you is doing Android
development?
And who of you is mostly here
to learn about Gradle?
So I once gave that talk at a
Java Enterprise conference.
And I thought, hey, this
is really a hot topic.
And I was asking, who is doing
Android Development, not a
single hand.
I was like, hm, ah.
So this is a really
nice mixture.
And the other interesting
thing I found out--
initially, I wasn't aware, in
Europe, how separate those
communities are.
So I was talking with them, how
excited we are about the
Android store.
And then I was saying stuff
like, oh yeah, we think
Android will become important.
So well, you think so?
Yeah.
So it's kind of an interesting
experience to see.
Although, it's Java based, that
there are, at least in
quite a few areas of the
world, really separate
communities.
And I'm excited that we have
a really nice mix here.
So let's start.
What is Gradle?
So Gradle is a general purpose
build and automation tool.
And we see two axes to describe
where we want to go
and where we are.
So one is the horizontal axis.
It's the platforms we are
already covering or are going
to cover in the future, so that
would start with Java and
Google Scholar, now Android.
We're working with high
intensity of work classes in,
if that's possible, which will
then also be interesting for
group and case support, from
an endpoint point of view.
We have JSON support
for JavaScript.
iOS, we have some
wrapping around
xcode.net, not so much yet.
So that is the horizontal axis,
where we just want to
appreciate the reality that
the software stacks--
nowadays, they are
into a genus.
It's no longer, in the old days,
people were thinking, I
hate the way genus software
stacks are
kind of a legacy burden.
We all know that the software
stacks of the
future have to be genus.
And the building of the
information tool has to
request that fact.
It has to be able to make all of
those platforms first class
citizens and not say, OK,
I'm a Java build tool.
And now, let's somehow try
to squeeze some Glasgow
support into it.
So it has to be open for that.
And Android is a really nice
example of how open the Gradle
platform is in Java.
So we'll talk about that.
So the other axis is what
we call beyond build.
Yes, originally we have
Build Tool and all--
so filing, and then creating
[INAUDIBLE].
But then we have a lot of
functionality for interesting
testing scenarios, interesting
integration-testing scenarios.
We now added features where you
can use your local Gradle
build and use a build forum, to
distribute your integration
tasks across that build forum.
Dependency management is another
very important topic.
We'll talk a little bit about
that later on; configuration
management; deep CI integration;
the whole
promotion and releasing and
staging of your software; and
finally, provisioning.
So all those areas Gradle plays
a role, sometimes by
integrating with our tools,
sometimes by natively
implementing them.
So just to give you
an overview--
AUDIENCE: I'm really
sorry to interrupt.
Someone pointed out in the back.
they can't hear you in
the back because you're
wearing your mic
for the live stream.
This is the mic for
the auditorium.
And it's a little
bit sensitive.
If you're a little bit closer
to that, the people in the
back will be able to hear you.
I'm sorry about that.
HANS DOCKTER: It's good
that you mentioned it.
So usually, people complain that
I'm speaking too loud, at
least at home.
[LAUGHING]
AUDIENCE: Is that OK
in the back now?
AUDIENCE: Better.
AUDIENCE: So although it's now
a challenge to watch, to see
the screen, I will
figure that out.
AUDIENCE: I'm sorry.
HANS DOCKTER: Is that
OK in the back?
Excellent, OK.
And to give you an overview of
where Gradle is, let's say,
before Android--
so Gradle is used for quite a
while in massive production
builds, NS-40 switched almost
before they switched their
stack to Gradle, many other
companies, major financial
institutes.
One of the biggest investment
banks is using it for 5,000 of
their developers.
This is not boasting.
It's just to give you an idea
of where we are coming from,
before the Android team
made the decision.
Hey, let's use Gradle.
So Gradle is a well-established
technology in
many areas.
We had, a couple of weeks ago,
our first conference The
Gradle Summit, in
the Bay Area.
We have another one in London
at the end of the year.
And now, [INAUDIBLE]
is coming.
So that is basically
where Gradle is.
And then, we got really excited
that Gradle is going
to be the new Android
build system.
So what exactly does it mean?
Initially, people thought, hey,
Gradle will be used for
building Android SDK.
But that's not what this is
about, as most of you know.
So it's a combination.
It's basically Gradle+.
The Android Gradle Plugin that
is maintained by the Google
Android team.
It's not maintained by us.
They are developing that, in
close cooperation with us.
Last, IDE integration,
a very important
piece of the puzzle--
most of you have heard
about Android Studio.
And that is, by itself,
very exciting.
But what is also very exciting
for us is that, in cooperation
with the Android team, we think
it is a showcase for a
state of the art build system
for any domain.
There are really cool features
we think should be developed
the same way for other
platforms.
And we'll talk about that
during my talk.
OK.
So what is so exciting
about that new build
system, in mind opinion?
So one thing is, it is
heavily declarative.
What does it mean,
declarative?
So you all know.
And I guess you all
know Maven.
So an imperative build system is
basically where you-- like
an and-- in your build script,
you write the target.
And then you execute
this target.
So basically, the build author
has the granularity of the
executional unit.
That's how you model
your build.
You use the executional units
and link them together.
And then you execute them.
And a declarative build system
is a different animal.
The build author does not
necessarily work on the
executional unit path.
But the build author can use
many extractions, from which
the executional units
are derived.
That's an example.
Oops, sorry.
So this is a very simple
Gradle built.
It's empty.
And if you're now go to the
command line and ask Gradle,
hey, what can I do
with this build.
It will tell you there are a
couple of built-in tasks.
There's a set up task,
where you can
generate a template project.
There are tasks where you can
watch dependencies and stuff
like that, but no
domain-specific tasks.
You could now do it the end way
and specify the tasks you
want to execute.
But when we say it's a
declarative build system, we
mean that you can do something
like this.
You say, hey, Gradle, I want to
build an Android project.
And then you specify a couple
of more properties, like the
SDK version and the Build
Tools version.
And that's it.
With those few lines, you can
now go to Gradle and say, hey
Gradle, what can I do
with this project.
And there's now quite
a lot that you can
do with this project.
You can assemble it.
It means building the SDKs.
You can install them to
a virtual device.
You can uninstall them.
You can run all the instrument
tests, et cetera, et cetera.
So you didn't need to specify
those executionable units.
And you won't have to specify
each one by one.
Declarative means you add an
abstraction that automatically
creates those executionable
units for you.
And Android is interesting
because even simple Android
projects are much more complex
than a simple Java project.
This complexity is hidden,
to some degree.
So if you now ask Gradle, show
me all of the tasks, all the
executionable units that I added
after our heading of the
Android plugin.
You see there's now a lot
going on, the AID,
Renderscript functionality, all
the resource processing,
et cetera, et cetera.
Android is a very complex
workflow, simple line,
ProGuard stuff.
And you all know that.
And one thing Gradle tries
to do is to hide as much
complexity as possible for a
normal Android developer.
So that is what we think are
a normal life cycle phase.
And usually, you're not
interested in executing the
zipalign task by itself.
So we would now say, Gradle,
hey, build everything.
And everything is up to date,
because I tried it out before.
And what you end up with
is now all the ATKs
that you have specified.
So let's go back.
And let's think a little bit
about how this works.
So how could Gradle just
compile that build?
Well, the Android plugin
is making a couple of
assumptions.
It's making, for example, an
assumption where do you put
your main Android code.
And what I mean with main code,
I will talk about a
little bit later.
So if you stick to the
assumptions like, they live in
source main Java and source main
assets and source main
resources and the
AndroidManifest.xml is here.
Then you don't need to specify
anything of where your code
lives, when you put your test
in Source, instrumentTest,
they will be automatically
executed.
And the same is true for the
output of the build.
If you now go into the build
directory, you didn't need to
specify where to
put the stuff.
So you could have a look
at the APK directory.
And here we go.
There you see all the APKs
that are built by Gradle.
It's all defined
by conventions.
So that is one thing that
I mean with declarative.
People who know Maven kind
of get the idea.
But this is a declarativeness
that you say, this is an
Android project.
There's a certain
rigidity in it.
This saying, this is an Android
project is what we
call a project-level element
and tells a specific story.
And the interesting thing with
the Android plugin is that you
have many ways now to customize
that story.
And what the Android folks did--
they created a language
that allows you to elegantly
customize typical variations
of Android applications
and Android libraries.
So for example, they introduced
the concept of a
build type.
What is a build type?
A Build Type is an abstraction
that controls
how an app is built.
So for every build type, you can
specify additional source
code and resources.
So the main code base is used
by any APK that is produced.
And now you can additionally
specify source code that
should be only used for
this build type or
for that build type.
The Android plugin
automatically, by default,
adds a debug and release
build type.
And for example, the debug build
type automatically uses
the debug signing.
And of course, the release build
type is not doing that.
And you can specify different
program options
and things like that.
So there are two default
build types.
But you can define your
own build types.
One example would
be, Dick Wall,
from the Scala community.
He's really interested in
using Scala for Android
applications.
And one problem he has-- he
always has to ship the Scala
library with an Android
application.
And what he would like to do is,
to make it small, he wants
to use Proguard to
really shrink it.
But doing this during
development really reduces the
performance.
So what he would like to is he
wants to stick with the debug
build type that is not doing
any Proguard and with the
release that is doing
the Proguard stuff.
But he also wants to introduce a
staging build type, which is
then used by the QA folks, which
does all the Proguard
stuff but still has the
Debug Flag and the
Debug Signing activated.
So that the QA can work with and
APK that is very close to
the production APK.
That is the stuff you can do
with different build types.
So we look at an example.
So here you can see another
basic Android project.
But we do a little
bit more here
So we, for example, define some
signing configuration.
It should be used by
the releasable APK.
We also define an additional
build type, with staging.
We additionally configured the
debug build type that was
added by the Android plug in.
And then we also specify
the test build type.
We tell the test task, hey, use
this APK, the debug APK
basically, for running tests.
We could easily parameterize
that.
Then we say, on the
local machine, use
the debug build type.
On the CI machine, use the
staging build type.
And if we now go to this
project, we can say, hey
Gradle, what can I
do with this guy.
And you now see all the stuff.
OK, no.
It is OK, sorry.
So I missed that.
So there is an Assemble Staging
task, an Assemble
Release task, an Assemble
Debug task.
There is an Install
Staging task.
So what you get, when you
define this guy here.
This is a little mini framework
that you apply.
You say, hey, I have a
staging build type.
And that triggers a
couple of stuff.
First of all, it means you
could now create a source
directory, Source, Staging.
And it will be automatically
picked up and put into the
staging APK.
And it creates a little life
cycle for all the stuff that's
related to the Staging
build type.
You can assemble it.
You can install it.
You can uninstall it.
So this is what we call a
dynamic declarative element.
And imagine you would have to
write this here with ANT.
And I will bring another
example for that soon.
So this is one concept that
was added to describe a
variation of an Android
program.
And now, another important
concept is Product Flavor.
So this is a way, as written
there, to generate several
versions of the same app.
So you might want to have an
application that is almost the
same, with some variations for
the free application and the
paid application.
And this is a really
flexible context.
So you can, for example, not
just add specific source code
and resources to the free and
the paid application.
You can also add different
kind of dependencies.
And you can also add different
kinds of check rules.
You could add a plugin to all
your Android applications, a
Gradle plugin that says, for all
persons the free Product
Flavors of my Android
application, do a check
whether any of the custom
dependencies of that APK is
commercial.
So you customize other app
parameters like a target SDK
version, signing in
for package name,
and things like that.
Let's look at an example.
So here we have added
two Product Flavors
one is called free.
The other is called paid.
And you see, there is now
an optional source free
directory, which will
be better added.
The binaries will be added
to the free APK.
And you see, you can also easily
add tests just for the
paid variant, for the paid
flavor, by following the
simple convention.
Call you directory source
instrumentTestPaid.
And it will automatically
pick up and be tested.
That's one of the nice things.
With the Android plugin, you
don't need any separate
projects for your tests.
So tests are part of
the same projects.
The Android manifest for
the test package is
automatically generated.
You don't need to
worry about it.
It just works.
And if you think now, what it
would take to write and
Android build that covers
all those requirements.
Sorry, an end build, that
would be quite a
few lines of code.
So have a look at this guy
and see what he can do.
And you see there's now some
Cartesian product, right.
You can assemble the
free debug version.
You can assemble the free
release version, the free
staging version.
You can also say, assembleFree,
which assembles
all the different variants of
all free version, debug,
release, and staging.
And at the same time, you can
also say, assembleStaging,
which builds the free and the
paid version, for the staging
build type.
And the same is true
for tests.
You have a separate pay test.
You have a separate free test.
Usually, you don't need
to bother about that.
That is happening on the road,
all the test execution.
So that's way, you think very
elegantly deal with the very
typical use case, that you have
slight variations of an
application.
So who of you is using Maven
for Android development?
Who of you is using ANT for
Android development?
Who of you is using no
particular build tool for
Android development,
just the IDE?
OK, thanks.
And if you look at that, if I
went to here, gradle tasks -
all, I would get quite
an explosion of
tasks, hundreds of tasks.
don't need to bother
about that.
But if I had to do this with a
non-declarative build, there
are quite a few tasks to
define, like with ANT.
If I would do that with a
declarative build system that
doesn't have this model,
this flexibility, I
would be kind of stuck.
I would possibly need to create
a separate project for
every barrier, a project for my
main code base, a project
for my free code base, for my
release code base, for my
staging code base.
Additional projects for the
testing of the main code base,
for the testing of the free code
base, you get the idea.
I have a pretty simple Android
application with some variants.
And I end up with 40 or 50
sub-projects, which is kind of
ridiculous.
And we already used
the terminology.
So one thing the Android package
is introducing is the
concept of a Build Variant.
You have different variants,
as we described.
And there are rules to manage
the resource overlay.
So you can overwrite code
and resources of
the main code base.
And flavor wins over main.
And build type wins
over flavor.
But there's even more
flexibility and power.
What if you have multiple build
flavors, in terms of
multiple dimensions
of build flavor.
Let's say, you have a free and
a paid version for the
different build types.
Now, you also have different
versions for ARM and
inter-processors.
And that's where there's also
the concept of a Product
Flavor group.
So you can add basically as many
dimensions as you want.
So you can have a free and
a paid version and
then x86 and ARM.
So you have now an
additional, more
complex Cartesian product.
But it's all very manageable
with because you have the
proper abstractions to
deal with those.
And you don't need to deal
with the implementation
details to build all those
and to test all those.
Let's look at an example
for those.
So here we have something a
little bit more abstract.
So we introduce here the flavor
groups, group1 and group2.
And the f1 flavor belongs
to group1.
The f2 flavor belongs
So that could be
paid and free.
And the flavor group
could be version.
fa and fb could be
ARM and x86.
And the flavor group
could be maybe i or
something like that.
And if you now go to this guy
and you ask, what can I do
with this project.
It's now quite a bit.
You see all the different
things you can install.
And the good thing is, you
always have aggregating tasks.
You can say, just build me every
APK or build me every
debug version of all the
different flavors and
combinations, F1Fa,
F1Fa debug.
You get the idea.
So there is also a
library plugin to
support library projects.
As part of this new build
system, there is a new form
for Android libraries.
It's called AAR.
And it produces Android
library bundle.
You can upload them to any Maven
or Ivy repository and to
contain the compiled code,
resources, and then additional
Proguard rules, and
stuff like that.
And it's a first
class citizen.
You can easily have dependencies
from and Android
application to an
Android library.
And of course, Gradle knows
what to do with that.
So what we have here, what the
Android plugin provides to the
Android developer
is a rich model.
And so instead, you have to
think how can I implement the
Android requirements with the
concept of the build system.
For example, in ANT,
how do I have to
create all the targets?
Or in Maven, how do I have to
create all the subprojects?
It provides you a
much better way.
It provides you the language
of the solution space.
You can just say, hey, this is
how my Android project is
structured.
It should look like.
Those are the flavors.
And the rest is figured out by
the build system, which is a
much more efficient way to solve
such a problem-- much
lower learning curve and much
better maintainability, much
better visibility.
So a rich model has
many advantages.
We will talk more about
the advantages later.
So you have even pretty complex
scenarios like this
multi-flavored application I've
shown you, that would
take thousands of lines
of ANT code.
You can describe with,
I don't know, with
something like 30, 40 lines.
So that's one of the things I
really like with the Android
plugin, that they are pushing
this concept of a rich
declarative build system that
models to the main, to a state
that is very, very convincing.
I'm very excited about that
because I think that's how a
build system should work.
It should provide
your language of
the solution space.
Of course, this is all
highly customizable.
If you have some special
requirements, you can create
any low-level custom Gradle task
and hook that into you
lifestyle, whatever
you want to do.
OK.
So one other thing that is very
cool about this new build
system is that it's now also a
base for Android-specific.
It's Gradle enriched.
And the Android plug
in is what we
consider the base plugin.
It has no implementation
aspect.
It's just a semantical thing.
It's a base plugin.
It's the core plugin for a
specific platform, for the
Android platform.
Now, other plugins, like the
Droidcon plugin or other
testing providers, they can now
write their own plugins
that hook in with the Android
core plugins.
So for example the guys
from MoneyMall--
I don't know who knows
that company.
This is a company that
provides virtual
devices in the cloud.
And so if you write a single
line, applied like in
MoneyMall, what this plugin
does, it automatically rewires
how the Android plugin
executes the tests.
It no longer looks for virtual
devices locally.
It automatically routes them
into the cloud and executes
them in parallel.
And gets the test
reports back.
So it's completely
test transparent.
with a one-liner.
And this is because the Android
core plugin provides
so many hooks, so that this
other plugin can hook into the
Android core plugin
and rewire it.
And say, the testing should, if
you're using MoneyMall, the
testing should happen a little
bit differently.
So it is very easy for the
user to make use of the
Android tooling automation
system.
So they're are now plugins out
there for Roboelectric, for
MoneyMall, for Troycon.
So initially, mostly from the
testing providers, a lot of
other cool stuff
is yet to come.
So there are a couple of generic
concepts that are
brought into the open by the
Gradle Android plugin.
So one interesting thing is the
source to output mapping.
In Gradle, you have abstractions
to model a
logical group of sources.
And initially, in Gradle, it
was always, you have this
group of sources, like
some Java directory.
And there is exactly one
binary, one jar that
comes out of that.
With Android, this
is now different.
You have multiple groups
of sources that should
end up in one APK.
And this is a similar concept.
We're now also using for
our C/C++ support.
So you have a logical group
of sources, even
from different languages.
You have group of C sources and
a group of C++ sources,
that it should end
up in one binary.
And of course, what we don't
want you to do is, that you
have to the wiring yourself.
So we provide you very nice
abstractions that you can
assign binaries to different
groups of sources, without
bothering about how to
compile archiving.
It's actually taking place.
Another thing of the source to
output mapping that's also
from the C/C++ world
is that you have a
logical group of sources.
But you want to have multiple
binaries like aesthetic and a
shared library.
So this is a concept that was
enriched by the experience
with the Android plugin.
The other very exciting
concept is the
concept of a variant.
You see this all over
the place, not just
in the Android world.
We just were at the client.
And they had some 20-year-old
legacy software stack.
And they had exactly
the same problem.
They had a main core base.
And then they were shipping
software to different banks.
Some of the banks were
using WebLogic.
Others were using WebSphere,
different versions of those
application containers.
And they needed to have certain
variations for all of
those different application
servers.
It's exactly the same thing.
There is a main code base.
And then you have certain
variations.
Obviously, in the C/C++ world,
this is a core concept, the
idea of variants.
And it is the next thing that
is pushed by Android.
It's the idea of variant-aware
dependency management.
So if you have different
dependencies between libraries
and applications in the Android
world, we can use the
variant information for smart
conflict resolution.
So we could always decide,
this is the debug APK.
So this debug APK should also
use the debug variant of the
depending library.
You shouldn't be required
to specify that.
And the same is true
in the C/C++ world.
So you can find automatically
the affinities that the
dependencies are assigned
the right way.
So this was kind of the
modeling aspect
of the Android plugin.
But there's also kind of a
deeper aspect why Gradle was
chosen as the platform.
And one reason is performance.
And Android builds can be
heavy on performance.
And there are many things that
Gradle offers in regard to
performance.
So I will just pick on of the
things we like in particular.
It's the incremental build.
So the example I'm showing now
is not for Android project.
It's for a normal
Java project.
But it's the same concept.
Sorry, I have to go back.
So here, we don't say, applied,
like in Java.
We say applied like
in Android.
And we stick to certain
conventions, like the
production code lists
in source main Java.
The test code list in source
test Java, et cetera.
It's the same game
as we're playing
with the Android plugin.
So this is a very short
build script.
And now we're using Gradle
to execute that build.
And we say, Gradle,
do a clean build.
And everything is built.
And the next thing,
we're now saying,
don't do a clean build.
And see, everything
is up to date.
So now the question is,
how reliable is that.
So let's play around
a little bit.
Let's, for example, change
a production class.
Let's move a field from
And let's re-execute
the build.
And you see, Gradle
has figured out.
Hey, the code has changed.
So the jar needs
to be rebuilt.
The test needs to be re-executed
because the class
passed, whatever.
For a test has changed.
The production code has
changed, et cetera.
So we haven't saved
much time here.
But at least the incremental
build works reliably.
So let's do something else.
Let's remove this comment.
say, gradle build.
And now it's interesting.
Gradle recompiled the sources.
But the bytecode
hasn't changed.
So the jar is still
up to date.
It's the same bytecode as
when you ran it before.
So therefore, everything
is up to date.
So that was a nice time
saver, even for
this very small project.
And you can even change
properties
in your build script.
So let's change the source
compatibility version.
And if you re-execute that,
Gradle picked that up.
And everything is to
rebuilt because the
bytecode has changed.
And the tests are re-executed.
So you can also change the
version of junit that you're
using to run your tests and
compile your tests.
And this is also picked up.
And you see everything is up
to date, until you come to
compiling the tests.
And that is where the tests
are recompiled because the
class path has changed.
So it is sensitive in
regard to input.
It is also sensitive in
regard to the output.
So if you remove, for example,
a compact class and you rerun
the build, what you can see
is, the classes were
recompiled.
But the bytecode
hasn't changed.
So all the rest is
still up to date.
So an interesting question is
now, how can you use that if
you have custom build logic.
So let's say you have
some XML file.
And the requirement you're
having is, you want to create,
for every node of this XML file,
for every mountain node,
you want to create a text file
where the name of the mountain
is the name of the text file.
And the height of the
mountain is the
content of the text file.
So let's create some logic for
this in the gradle build.
So we create a task,
generateMountainFiles.
And we have some scripting logic
that passes the XML file
and creates the text files.
We don't need to go
into the details.
Now, one thing that
is very handy.
You can do [INAUDIBLE] case task
execution, also for all
the tasks you've seen before.
So if you say, GMF, Gradle
will find the appropriate
task, in that case,
generateMountainFiles.
So if we now look, we
need to refresh.
There's now Mountains directory,
with a K2 text and
a Mount Everest text.
Don't bother about
the numbers.
They're wrong.
And now, the question is,
if I we execute this--
and I haven't changed
anything--
will it be up to date.
Or will it be not up to date?
What do you think?
I haven't changed anything
of the input.
And we're claiming Gradle
has incremental build
functionality.
So let's see.
No, Gradle regenerated
the mountain files.
It regenerated again.
So what is going wrong here?
So well, we also
have a company.
We have Gradleware.
And incremental build for custom
build logic, is it
commercial?
No.
It's not.
So one thing we don't like here
is, we don't want to see
too much scripting logic in our
build script, mixed with
the declarative parts
of the build.
So what we do now, initially, we
extract the logic into what
we call the custom task.
We call it ConvertMountainXml.
And we specify the properties
of this custom task to XML5,
which is the mountains XML file,
the separator in the
text file, the output directory,
which is the
mountains directory.
And then we specify the task
action, which is basically the
same logic as above.
And now, we are changing this
and saying, this task is now
from type ConvertMountainXml.
And we specify now
the properties.
So it's the mountains directory
where the mountain
text file should be placed.
the XML file that needs
to be passed, the
input file into separator.
So if we now execute this build,
let's do a clean build
as a start.
And if we now re-execute it,
what you can see is, now
everything is up to date.
And how does it work?
Well, let's first check
whether they are still
product, the mountain,
the text files.
Yes.
Let's change a number in here.
Let's re-execute.
And you see, this change
was detected.
And the mountains files
were regenerated.
If I execute it again,
it's up to date.
And you can, for example, also
change separator value.
If you now have a look,
this change in the
property was detected.
And the separator is
now a semicolon.
So how does this work?
Well, it's extremely simple.
You just need annotate
the properties
of your custom task.
This is an input file.
This is an input property.
This is the output directory.
That's all you need to do.
You don't need to tell Gradle
anything about the incremental
build or whatever.
Just what are the input and
outputs of your task?
And from that, Gradle can do
all the smartness that is
necessary to provide you with
an incremental build.
But it also provides you
some other logic.
For example, you get
automatically validation of
your input value.
So if you specify this check,
you don't need to code in your
custom task.
It is automatically done
because you specified a
property as an input value.
OK.
So there's another thing
that came out
all the Android effort.
Initially, the incremental build
function in Gradle was a
binary function.
So Gradle was telling a task,
either nothing has changed.
So you don't need
to do anything.
Or something has changed.
So you need to redo
everything.
It was a binary thing.
And what we added as part of the
Android cooperation, there
is now an API.
So if you write a task that
can be very smart
if stuff has changed.
You can now ask Gradle.
When the generic incremental
build in Gradle figures out
something has changed, it passes
you the information of
what exactly has changed of
what exactly was removed,
since you last ran the build.
And then you can be really
smart and say, OK.
I only need to generate the
stuff that has changed.
Another thing we do for
the performance
is the Gradle Daemon.
The Gradle Daemon is a
long-running process.
So when you use Gradle with
the Gradle Daemon, a
long-running JBM is created
with a warmed up Gradle.
And when you execute the build
a second, third or fourth
time, the responsiveness
will be each better.
Especially when you work with
dynamic languages that need
some warm up time, then it is
a very important feature.
OK.
There are some other reasons why
Android chose Gradle for
the Android build system.
It's that it's already a
platform, like the incremental
build, that provides a lot
of interesting services.
And I want to show you
one of those services
that is really cool.
And I guess most of you
are using, as soon as
you're using Gradle.
So in Gradle, we have the
concept of a wrapper.
So for any Gradle, Android,
Java, whatever, you can
specify a wrapper task.
It's a one-liner basically.
In the latest version of Gradle,
you don't even need to
specify it in the
build script.
It's automatically available.
And as the build master, you can
do and the following, you
can execute this wrapper task.
And what wrapper task does, it
creates a couple of files in
the route directory
of your project--
gradlew, gradlew.bat, and the
directory, gradle-wrapper,
with a gradle-wrapper.jar, which
only has a couple of
kilobytes and gradle-wrapper
properties.
So what you're doing with
those four files, you're
committing them to
version control.
And the next time someone checks
out version control and
wants to build this project,
this person doesn't need to
have Gradle installed.
This person can just use
the gradlew script.
And then Gradle will be
automatically downloaded for
them, with the URL specified
in the Gradle wrapper
properties file.
And the build will work.
And the next time, of course,
Gradle won't be downloaded
another time because it's
in a local cache.
So if you want that all your
team is upgrading to a new
version of Gradle, you just
change the distribution URL,
commit it to version control.
The next time some of your
developers do a check out and
run the build, they will
automatically pick up the
newest version of Gradle.
So you have zero administration
on the client side.
That's one aspect of that.
The other aspect of that
is historical build,
reproducible builds.
So we have client in the
medical industry.
And I guess Android is more
and more into also I think
mission-critical areas.
They get auditing once a year.
And if they can't show that
they're able reproducibly
build their software, they have
to call back all of the
medical devices they have
sold to the hospitals.
They are no longer allowed
to have them in use.
So for them, reproducibility is
a mission-critical aspect.
Financial industries, there
are sometimes similar
requirements.
It depends on the domain,
whether this is an interesting
feature or not, the
reproducibility aspect of it.
In any case, it's very
convenient, whatever domain
you are working with.
Another thing that is
interesting is the concept of
init scripts in Gradle.
So if you have multiple projects
that share similar
configuration information.
Like here, we have a project
that is called
testing with Gradle.
And we specified the location
where to retrieve the
dependencies from.
What we did now, we removed
that information.
And we now created an init
script, what we call an init
script, where we put that
information in.
Get your dependencies
from Maven central.
So what we can do now on the
command line is, we can say,
hey Gradle, run this build.
And this build would
fail without--
if we wouldn't specify the -i
init script, the build would
fail because it wouldn't
know where to get the
dependencies from.
But with this init script, you
can inject this information
into any Gradle build.
And the build works
and runs the test.
And one thing I want to use
to show you is, Gradle is
extremely customizable.
You can put amazing stuff into
the script, to do really deep
customization.
So for example, let's assume
what you want to do is say, I
want to issue a warning to my
developers, if any of their
tests is taking longer
than 20 milliseconds.
So how would you do that with
other build systems?
With Gradle, you can do
the following way.
You can't say, in the init
script, give me the Gradle
object which represents
the build wrap time.
And then you say, hey Gradle,
after you have evaluated all
the projects, give me
the route project.
In the simple builds we
have seen so far,
there is only one project.
There is only a route project.
But you can, in Gradle, have
mighty module builds, where
you have multiple project
in one build.
And then you say, iterate
over all the projects.
And for all the test tasks, I
want to hook in a listener
into the test task.
So this listener is
called after test.
So Gradle now calls this
hook after it has
executed the test method.
And it gives you the results.
And you can then calculate
the time it took to
execute that test.
And if the time is
greater than 20
milliseconds, issue a warning.
OK.
So let's see whether
this works.
And here we go.
In real time, you get the
warning that the tests are
long running, with a
few lines of code.
And you can do interesting
stuff.
You could, for example, say,
I want to the let the build
fail, if the tests
are long running.
But I only want to do this on
continuous integration,
because there I have a
defined environment.
You can use this injection
principal that you inject
additional behavior, depending
on which platform you're
running-- either local build or
the continuous integration
build or the build that
is the release build.
Yet that gives you a
lot of flexibility.
And the example shows how deep
you can enter the guts of
Gradle runtime to get
information, to help the AVR,
et cetera, et cetera.
We had a user and now we have
multiple users, actually, they
have a lot of problems with
fragile integration tests.
And they had one with
a couple of very
important integration tests.
And the rule for them was,
if they fail the
first time, it's OK.
If they fail a second
time, then it's
considered a failure.
Otherwise, it's considered
a success.
You can't help laughing
about this company.
But it's a hard problem
sometimes to solve.
One of the team members there
was Szczepan Faber, the
founder of Mockito.
You don't have to tell him
about testing and being a
smart developer.
They couldn't change it, also
for the reason that it was a
different team.
It was related to
infrastructure.
So those are sometimes the
realities you run into in
enterprise.
You can say, this is not
a good situation.
Well, we all know that.
But that doesn't help
you in that moment.
You need a tune that is humble
and say, OK, I'll give you a
took kit to solve that.
Don't ask us to put, in the
Gradle API, a new method--
succeed after two failures
or something like that.
We won't do that.
Your pathologies won't pollute
the Gradle API.
But you can use the tool kit
to solve this problem.
And as soon as you're in
a more complex delivery
scenario, there's always
unanticipated stuff happening.
And you don't need a tool that
thinks it knows how the world
looks like for you.
You need a humble tool that
provides you opinions, out of
the box behavior.
But when you really need it,
must provide you a tool kit to
solve you custom problems.
And at least not stand
in the way.
And even better, it should make
it very efficient for you
to solve those problems.
And this goes one step further,
this concept.
What you can do with this init
script, you can now go to your
local Gradle distribution.
And every Gradle distribution
has an init.d directory.
And in this init.d directory,
you can put an arbitrary
amount of init scripts.
And we're doing this
right now.
And if we now run this project,
we see this init
script is now automatically
applied.
You can now argue, with
good reasons.
I don't want to mess around
with my local Gradle
distribution.
Especially people used to
wrapper, they don't even know
where it's located.
So this is now the interesting
thing.
You can use the Gradle wrapper
and can let the Gradle wrapper
point to a Gradle distribution
on a shared network drive, on
your binary repository manager,
with init scripts
that preconfigure your local
build environment.
You get the idea.
And then when the developers
use the Gradle wrappers
scripts, they'll automatically
download to Gradle
distribution with your init
scripts, where you can do all
kinds of stuff.
You can redefine where to get
the dependencies from.
You can specify rules, whatever
you want, with the
deep API that Gradle
provides you.
So no build wikis, the
developers have to read how to
set up their local build
environment.
It will just work.
So the init scripts and the
init.d directory, in
conjunction with the wrapper,
is a really, really cool
feature, and much appreciated,
especially by
the enterprise users.
You can also nail down other
aspects of your build
environment.
The JVMArchs.
used by the Gradle build
tool or with Java
version need to be used.
So you can put this also
in version control.
With other build tools, you have
to create an ANT ops or
Maven ops environment variable,
which is global and
which is not in version control,
which you have to
describe in the build wiki.
Every developer has to set that
environment variable.
In Gradle, you just put
a Gradle properties
file in your project.
And those properties
are defined.
They are version controlled.
And the developers don't even
need to be aware of that.
OK.
Another interesting aspect of
the Android plugin is the deep
IDE integration.
So what is that about?
A major thing the Android folks
wanted to resolve is
that they basically had to
maintain, for Android, two
build systems.
One was the ANT-based build
system that you would be using
on a continuous integration
machine.
The other was the build system
they had to provide with the
ADT tooling, two different
build systems.
Because the IDE was
not delegating
to any build system.
It was doing the build
action themselves.
And this is problematic and
has a lot of problems, for
multiple reasons.
So one is--
and if let the IDE not
do any build actions.
But the IDE would reach out
to the build system to do
whatever needs to be
done, compiling,
texting, testing, et cetera.
Then you still have the
richness of an IDE.
But the feedback you get from
the IDE is close to the
canonical build that runs on
continuous integration.
Separate jobs for different
build variants, depending on
how long the tests are running
or how many tests they have,
we will provide you, like for
the IDEs, a model for Jenkins,
that you can, in very smart
ways, programmatically script
the job setup in Jenkins.
That's really good stuff.
So we talked about that.
So this is work in progress.
We started work on
that, together
with the Jenkins guys.
And Android, again, will be
leading the whole movement.
So the first platform
we implement that
for won't be Java.
It will be Android.
OK.
So this is the last
content slide.
So the deeper mission of Gradle
is related to the fact
that we see a lot of suffering
with any kind of medium or
large-scale software stack, in
regard to missing automations.
We see projects that
have build timed of
eight hours or 14 hours.
Distributed teams that hardly
ever get back to a state where
everything works together,
and all the
components can work together.
So a lot of waste, a lot of
wasting time because QA gets
crappy versions all the time.
And they have to wait another
day, until the four-hour-long
deployment is done for a new
version to try again.
The continuous delivery domain,
at the moment, is the
domain full of suffering.
And when I talk about
theoretical versus practical
freedom, theoretically, you
could solve all those
problems, even with ANT.
Although, it would be hard.
But there are only a few
companies in the world that
have the skills, the resources,
and the backing
from management, that they can
really achieve what is
theoretically possible for
a really good continuous
delivery pipeline.
And Google is one of those.
But there are not many.
And for the majority of
the companies, what is
theoretically possible is just
unachievable, because they
don't have the skills or the
resources with to implement
that with the legacy tooling.
And the job o Gradle is
basically to enable the big
majority of the companies to
get much closer to the
theoretical possibility of a
very strong, powerful, fast
continuous delivery pipeline,
as I said,
with reasonable effort.
There will always be
effort involved.
Modeling continuous delivery for
any organization with more
than 50 developers is a job,
the modeling of an
organization, at the end of the
day-- how they cooperate,
how they release.
But with reasonable effort,
that is our goal.
Gradle provides you the tool kit
that you can really push
your automation to the limits.
So Gradle is not so much about
the cookie-cutter solutions.
Gradle provides cookie-cutter
solutions.
We've seen some of
the examples.
But this is really what
an enterprise needs.
There are always customization
you need to do, always special
behaviors, special problems.
And Gradle is the tool
kit that you can
use to solve those.
If you want to learn more about
the new Android build
system there is very decent
documentation on the Android
tooling website.
If you want to learn more
about Gradle, go to
Gradle.org.
You can also subscribe to our
newsletters and notifications
if you're interested.
We also offer trainings for
Gradle and for Gradle Android.
And at the end of the day,
Gradleware is the company
behind Gradle.
So we know a lot about Gradle.
But we also know a lot
about continuous
delivery as a whole.
So if you have questions, if
you're struggling, if you want
to improve your continuous
delivery pipeline, go to our
website, fill out the
contact form.
We are more than happy to help
you with our experience.
We are involved with some of the
largest software stacks in
the world but also with many
smaller companies.
All of them can benefit
a lot from improving
their delivery pipeline.
And we help you with our
experience and our skills.
Yes, that's it.
Do we have any questions?
Yes, please.
AUDIENCE: I really liked the
idea of using a simulated
calculator tools to test with.
And you said that was coming.
Is there any time
frame for that?
And also, I didn't hear anything
about being able to
test on devices, pushing
out to devices.
HANS DOCKTER: OK.
So this is already available
for Testdroid.
They have released their first
version of the plugin and the
MoneyMall folks.
And I think the first
Roboelectric
plugin is out there.
I don't know about
the quality.
But this is already available.
I'm sorry.
The question was, I talked about
this additional Android
plugin with a testing domain,
from some of the testing
providers, when it
can be used.
And I said, this is already
available stuff.
They're working on it.
It will be improved.
But it's already available.
You can at least spike it
and see how much it
does what you want.
The other question was how, with
the Gradle Android build
system, you can work with
actual devices.
It's easy.
You have install tasks.
You have uninstall tasks.
So the build tool checks which
devices are available and then
pushes to them.
So this is kind of
a [? hybrid ?]
talk, by design.
So there is a really good talk
from Xavier Decoret.
He presented the build system at
the Google I/O conference,
with more details than
I did here, because
I had a mixed approach.
So that's available on the
Android web page and on Google
I/O channel.
So this is also where you can
learn more about some of the
stuff I have mentioned.
Yes, please.
AUDIENCE: So I do a lot of the
ANT scrips and trying to debug
those and track down which
targets are defined where.
And the properties is
kind of like a pain.
Is there an easy way to
debug Gradle scripts?
Is there IDE that really
makes it easy for you?
You can quickly go
to the target
definition and so forth?
HANS DOCKTER: Yes.
So you can debug on
the source level.
So we do this all the time.
And you can do that.
There's no problem.
And often, it's easy to
run down the bugs.
Sometimes--
and that's one area
we're invested in.
It's a little bit harder
with debugging.
You always can't
find the cause.
But we want to invest quite a
bit of effort over the next
six months, that in most of the
cases, the error message
should give you a good hint
what is going on.
This is sometimes still
a little bit
cryptic at the moment.
But yes, you can debug.
There was a question.
I say a hand before,
somewhere.
Yes, please.
AUDIENCE: So if you're importing
a module from like
Maven central.
And it'll say it's like
action bar share one.
But it includes and Android
manifest file.
Gradle refuses to compile
because now there's two
Android manifest files.
Is there any--
HANS DOCKTER: Yes.
So I think you're talking about
the old Maven library
form, right?
AUDIENCE: Go ahead and repeat
the question, Hans.
HANS DOCKTER: OK, sorry.
There was a question how Gradle
works together with the
Maven Android library
form, basically.
That's a feature, Edit in
Master, of the Android plugin.
So the next release
should make this
work without problem.
So many people ask for that.
Because they say, hey,
basically, I can't use it.
Because I can't use
those libraries.
So that is solved.
And that was one of the--
I would say-- number one
complaints about the current
state of the build system.
AUDIENCE: Is there support for
Atlassian Bamboo with Gradle?
HANS DOCKTER: Yes, so he's
saying support for Atlassian
Bamboo with Gradle.
Yes.
So Gradle works with
any CI server.
Some have a richer integration,
some not so rich.
But the main job, you can
do with any CI server.
AUDIENCE: So you showed us
inside Gradle task and it
showed a bunch of tasks.
Now, how many of those
were out of the box?
And how many were defined?
So it was per project.
It was for Android.
What is the difference between
the Android task
and the Java task?
They all just come free,
bundled with Gradle?
HANS DOCKTER: Yes.
It was just a few
lines of code.
There was nothing no custom
logic to load.
That all came from the
Android plugin.
There was nothing to
be done on my side.
AUDIENCE: What if you're not
using Android plugin, and
you're just using
regular Gradle?
HANS DOCKTER: So if you're using
the Gradle plugin, then
if you're using the Java plugin,
then you wouldn't get
all the Android tasks.
So you would get a life cycle
for a Java project.
And they share some of the life
cycle phases, like the
concept of assembling
of compiling.
But the Android life cycle
is much richer.
And you can easily work with
mixed projects in Gradle.
You can have a mighty module
build with a Java backend
service, with Android
application and all that.
So that is one of the
strengths of Gradle.
It can provide you a unified
view and a unified build
process, even if you're using
very different platforms.
Yeah, thanks a lot for
your attention.
I really enjoyed it.
[APPLAUSE]
VAN RIPER: So if you can stop
the live streaming.
So what we usually do at the
beginning is get a chance for
announcements.
So since you made it to the
end, I wanted people who I
didn't give a chance
to go down.
So come up her now,
really quick.
And then, what we'd like to do
is give those of you who
stayed patiently to talk
to the speaker.
But let's get quick
announcements first.
And then we'll do that.
GOPAL: Thanks, Van.
I'm Gopal.
VAN RIPER: Use the mic.
Just go closely.
GOPAL: I'm Gopal.
I normally come here to learn
one of the technologies and
also do networking.
I have good news to share.
Right now, I work for
a company called
lendingclub.com.
So it's a peer-to-peer
lending.
And we are growing, really
exponentially.
So we took a platform.
We took it five to six years to
fund the first $1 billion.
And the next seven months, we
reached the second $1 billion.
So we developed Java double
parse and the QA.
If you any of you have interest
or know any of your
friends, you can just
come to me.
VAN RIPER: Come and talk to
him before you leave, if
you're looking for a Java QA.
SUYASH: Hi, my name is Suyash.
I run the Bay Area Android
Study Group.
And we have a meetup,
coming up next week.
Chiu-ki Chan, she's an Android
expert, going to talk about
how do you handle a device
fragmentation and all those
bugs that come with it.
So it's on Wednesday July 17,
Bay Area Android Study Group.
I'll put a link on
the meetup board.
VAN RIPER: Put a comment
on tonight's meetup.
So everybody here can see it.
All right, that's it.
And now we can stay here
for a few more minutes.
So if some of you want to
go up and talk to Hans
personally, I'm sure he'd be
happy to talk to you at least
for a few minutes, before
he has to go.